the rules on this are very very clear um
you are not allowed to glorify Terror or
call for Terror on the streets of
Britain and that existed before the 2006
terrorism act banned glorification and
it certainly exists now uh if you stand
on the Streets of London Calling for
Jihad you are calling for Terror and
that is actually a place where free
speech is at its limit and is no longer
permissible murder you're not allow
you're not allowed to let me finish one
other case you're not allowed uh to
stand on Streets of London and call for
the murder of Jews or any other minority
and yet people have been getting away
with this Saturday after Saturday and
and and are the police arresting people
no no they're not the police last week
said we're outnumbered when they start
calling for Jihad that is calling for
violence when you say River to the Sea
it is calling for genocide when you
target Jewish businesses or you go to
specifically places where you know Jews
or Israelis are what should a liberal
Society do at that point